وكاله رويترز نقلت عن امين سر اللجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه حسين
الشيخ قوله ان السلطه الفلسطينيه هي
الممثل الشرعي للشعب الفلسطيني وستكون
مستعده للسيطره على غزه بعد الحرب وقال
الشيخ ان اتفاقات اوسلو نجحت جزئيا لانها
منحت الفلسطينيين هويه وادت الى اعاده
مليوني لاجئ الى الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه
من البلدان التي فروا اليها خلال حربي 48
و67 واكد حسين الشيخ ان وظيفته هي ال مع
اسرائيل لتخفيف معاناه الفلسطينيين مشيرا
الى ان السلطه الفلسطينيه اضعفت بسبب
الغارات الاسرائيليه وتوسيع المستوطنات
وفي اشاره الى حماس التي خاضت خمس حروب ضد
اسرائيل منذ عام 2008 قال الشيخ انه من
غير المقبول ان يعتقد البعض ان طريقتهم
ونهجهم في اداره الصراع مع اسرائيل كانت
المثل الاعلى والافضل وتساءل حسين الشيخ
قائلا انه بعد كل هذا وبعد كل ما يحدث الا
يستحق الامر اجراء تقييم جاد وصادق ومسؤول
لحمايه الشعب الفلسطيني وقضيته وهل تحق
الامر مناقشه هل يستحق الامر مناقشه
لاداره هذ هذا الصراع مع الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مضيفا ان السلطه الفلسطينيه
ابلغت الجانب الامريكي بالحاجه لجهد دولي
جديد لاقناع اسرائيل بحل شامل يشمل الضفه
الغربيه وقطاع غزه والقدس الشر
الشرقيه وقال ان 60% من غزه قد دمر وس
يكلف اعاده البناء 40 مليار دولار على مدى
عقود